so World economic Forum issues
phase out car ownership people can walk
or share
so
it's not so much that they want cars to
go away they just want your cars to go
away some people don't know this but
quite a few of the wef members
uh own interests in ride share programs
ride sharing apps
um you know these are basically cars
that are usually placed in urban cities
and
um their use throughout the day by
different people
you just you have an app you basically
tap the app on some sensor on the car
probably some kind of Bluetooth sensor
or something it builds your credit card
you hop in you drive the insurance the
plate the registration everything's
covered you don't have to worry about
anything you just drive to your next you
know destination and you throw the car
and they're a lot and you get out and
you're done with it you don't have to
deal with repairs maintenance tire
changes oil changes none of that stuff
so there's a lot of guys out there
that own interest in these Rideshare uh
sort of apps and pro not not Rideshare
in the sense of like uber but like car
sharing apps
um
I think it was
2009 or 10 I was at this Mastermind
event and one of the themes that was
going around like one of the common
sound bites that you started to hear a
lot around that time is in the future
you will have access to everything
but oh nothing
and it sounded like an interesting pitch
it sounded like something that you know
the techno guys the you know the putting
the butter in the coffee guys at the
time
um you know the all those woosa sort of
guys really you know like like they
really you know subscribe to the idea of
we don't yeah we need a car for I can
just tap my app because I like my phone
and my Ubers and all these sort of
things and rather than calling for a car
I can just walk up to a lot and get into
this car and drive away in it and not
have to worry about insurance parking
fees nothing nothing you just drive it
and you let it go and that's fine for
some people in the city but
cars are
personal for a lot of people men
especially
women it's kind of like a fashion object
it's like an accessory you know oh it's
got swoopy lines and it looks pretty
like with women when they see cars they
like like for example if they like hire
in German cars they don't care if it has
a M5 competition badge on the back
bumper they just want the BMW Randall on
the hood and on the back bumper and in
the center of the steering wheel so when
they take a picture of their wrist or
their watch or their diamond ring or
something like that it shows up a little
round will they don't really care if
it's an M car they just want the
experience of being in a premium you
know German automobile sort of thing so
a base model 3 Series would do
essentially
but men on the other hand they tend to
have a more intimate deeper connection
with cars
um the men that I roll with anyway we
certainly do because we do a lot of we
do a lot of miles on the highways when
it comes to rallies and even the back
roads and stuff like that but uh men in
general tend to have a connection with
vehicles they like it they you know it's
an extension of who you are
um you would see guys you'd probably get
them like even in their more you know
Season years that probably spent more
time cleaning and detailing and washing
and waxing and maintaining their cars
and what they do their homes
there's guys that I made this point the
other day I was on with um vigorous
Steve is kind of a buyer bro dude we
were talking about blood labs and
there's guys that will take oil out of
their engine when they do an oil change
they put it in this container it's
called Blackstone Labs the name of the
company and you ship it in and they
analyze your engine oil to see how much
copper is in it
um because that gives you some kind of
indication if the you know if the piston
rings are wearing sooner so what kind of
life you're going to get at the engine
so they go through all these markers and
they'll compare it up against other cars
and they'll tell you you know like all
this data but these are the same guys
that don't really care to run their
blood Labs like this is how much they
love cars like they'll run the labs on
the engine oil but they won't run Labs
on their own blood when it comes to
self-care but again the show's about
The Crazies sort of you know plans for
your vehicle so you got Klaus Schwabs
here sitting in some
I don't know beige sort of color Econo
box that's the other thing too they want
to take personality away from cars they
don't want them to reflect the owner's
image as they have in the past it's just
like well we'll just put some beige over
here and some darker beige over here
maybe we'll have laminate bamboo and
we'll call it you know the best Econo
box in the world
so this is how you know things are going
and they're having you know
conversations about Sky High uh fuel
prices that's one of the other slides
that I got up that's going to pop up too
the communal sharing of cars circular
approaches sounds like fun the global
Elites in Geneva Switzerland are now
instructing their young global leaders
embedded into governments this is what
they've done I'm going to show you a
recording in a in a short moment here
average car van in England just driven
four percent of the time so why do we
need all these vehicles why don't we
share them that's an interesting
argument sure
um four percent of the time of the day
yeah because you're probably driving you
know an hour in the morning an hour in
the evening but the truth of matter is a
lot of the cars are being used around
the same time especially for those that
are commuting or they're using them for
work related this is a picture of Davos
with everybody's private jet this is
this is fine this is completely okay
don't worry about the environment when
it comes to Flying our private jets even
if it's only 22 miles from one short
haul airport to another so I can hang
out with my buddies and show them my
private jet all of these jets are
absolutely okay but your cars they want
to Target by the way uh the total
emissions I was watching a video earlier
this week the total emissions of all the
automobiles in Great Britain amount to
two percent of the uh greenhouse gas
emissions in the world in total
these countries are not the problem
right it's countries in Asia and in
South America that are contributing uh
so I mean even if you took away all the
cars or you put kill switches in all of
them tomorrow and they couldn't drive
them unless the government said so uh
that wouldn't really do anything it
wouldn't even put a dent in the problem
so it's kind of an absurd
angle that they're that they're hitting
on this from but I think where they're
going is going to be climate lockdowns
next and we've heard a little bit of
this from a few others in the last
couple years and it seems to be
gathering a little bit of momentum let
me see if we got any sound bites on here
that are worth mentioning not really
it's just blah blah blah that came with
their Jets okay so we'll close that down
we'll deal with the kill switches in a
second
no thanks so here's another article from
the world economic Forum wants to pump
up gas prices even higher to save
democracy so one of their plans is to
make fuel more expensive because they
think that it's underpriced
um It's Kind of a Funny notion because
um what is this the Geneva Switzerland
one yeah this is the recent one from
Davos right so it's a bit of an article
and we're talking about what they're you
know blathering on about but you get the
idea from the from the title one of the
arguments that they make is that uh
petroleum-powered cars are damaging to
the environment and they try to argue
that electric cars aren't or aren't so
much there was a dude that was on um The
Joe Rogan podcast uh recently in the
last
um
I think two or three weeks I can't
remember his name but he wrote a book on
basically how they mine metals from
um I think it's a Congo
um the Republic of Congress it's
somewhere in Africa and the vast
majority of the rare earth metals that
they use in batteries that go in cars
come from there they're open pit mines
they're mostly kids working in there uh
they don't have safety equipment on
because you know if you're mining
something like Cobalt it's toxic it's
you know it's basically going to kill
you sooner
um and they buy it at dirt cheap prices
right so they're so they're mining all
of these Metals for batteries in cars
and one of the arguments that it that is
you know conveniently always made like
this is a bar graph here showing the
amount of metals that go into an
electric car uh versus a conventional
car you know when it comes to um aside
from the Bodywork you know like the
steel body panels or the aluminum body
panels depending on how the car is made
but there's significantly more uh rare
metals that are used in electric cars
here there's been a lot of studies done
that show you that the um
the impact of an electric car
it doesn't it doesn't get to net like
you basically have to drive it I think
it's something like 80 000 miles before
it becomes a wash versus a
um
gas powered car
um gas power cars are less damaging to
the environment immediately
um and if you factor in that most
electricity comes from coal fire plants
like they're not coming from nuclear
plants they're not coming from wind or
solar like winter solar amounts to
almost nothing if wind and solar was so
effective at producing electricity you
would see solar panels on the roofs and
hoods and trunk Lids of Teslas but you
don't because they're not efficient
enough they're they just don't do
anything I think there's a car company
it's um Fisker Henrik fris Fisker I'm
probably pronouncing his name wrong but
he was a dude that created the original
Fisker which was kind of a beautifully
designed electric car I think he worked
with Aston Martin and a few other car
companies but he created this electric
car that went nowhere kind of went
bankrupt now he's got this new one
coming out and it's got a big solar
panel on the entire roof of the car it's
like an SUV style car so it's quite
large right it's a people mover and I
think their pitch on the website is
something like oh you'll get about 1100
kilometers per year just off the solar
panel and driving alone now that's
assuming day late all the time your
car's parked outside and all these other
elements but solar panels aren't that
effective neither is when it producing
electricity so it mostly comes from cold
or shutting down nuclear plants because
those are big bad and scary even though
they're extremely efficient at producing
electricity for the size of them and uh
if they're run right are very clean they
produce no harmful emissions whatsoever
they're shutting those down though we've
got one here just on the east side of
Toronto and that one's shutting down
um and we don't have really anything to
replace it so I'm not really sure what
the government's plan is to sort of deal
with that
but
here's what they're saying in Canada now
the liberal government
new gas car sales will be banned by
2035.
it's 12 years 12 years away they are
they are planning to completely ban the
sale of new gas cars now that's not
saying they're going to take away your
existing cars they haven't gone that far
yet not to say they won't they won't but
they're they're saying you won't be able
to buy a brand new gas powered car after
2035. that's the plan anyway I don't
know if they've passed the legislation
where it's at but this is something
coming from our good friend Justine
Trudeau who was made famous during the
trucker convoys recently uh you know he
didn't like that they did scary things
in his town so he froze bank accounts
cancels insurance and did all kinds of
Nefarious things but he wants people to
switch to electric vehicles which if
we're being honest
I mean if you live in a country like
Canada we don't have a proper
infrastructure to get around in an
electric car uh we're not even close to
it uh you know gas stations have been
around for ages are obviously very
efficient you can refill and get your
full range within three minutes two
minutes I don't know how long it takes
to fill up a car a couple minutes
whereas if you want to get maybe like 60
or 70 percent charge out of an electric
car you need a high capacity charger it
has to be available nobody can be
plugged into it and you basically have
to plug in and wait for I don't know 45
minutes
walk around pick your nose look at the
sun look at the grass grow I don't know
what they expect you to do maybe they
want you to go shopping and spend money
in the stores but
um they're not particularly efficient at
refilling your range and getting you the
range you want and the other you know
convenient problem with it is
I think you guys have probably heard of
these things they're called cell phones
right and if you haven't noticed with
cell phones they have these like
electric batteries lithium-ion Cobalt
battery sort of in the in the device but
they never really seem to hold their
charge after about a year or two right
you always have to kind of keep them
plugged in or you have to have an
external you know battery Bank to keep
it charged up if you want to be able to
use it throughout the day that's a big
sale you know selling pitch buy this
phone it's got enough battery power for
a full day's use
[__] maybe for like the first month
or two and then you know the capacity
starts to go down
and the same thing sort of happens with
electric cars
um when I go to the gas station and I
fill up and I sit in the car it says
range 670 kilometers it's set 670
kilometers whether that was four years
ago when I got the car or today the size
of the gas tank doesn't change but the
size of your
um but the amount of charge your battery
Bank can hold an electric car
deteriorates over time and it
deteriorates further in the winter time
when it's cold or if you have to heavily
use lights air conditioning heating if
you have to heat up the batteries you
know if that's part of the system that's
integrated in or if you have to cool the
batteries depending on if that's
integrated in but your your experience
will vary as they say but generally
speaking if you buy an electric car and
you tend to get 670 kilometers in range
you know when you first get it probably
by year two or three you might have 560
kilometers in range or 590 you know
whatever it happens to deteriorate down
to because the batteries don't hold the
same amount of charge so it's the
equivalent of you buying a car R and
then the gas tank shrinks over time okay
so you get less range so that's another
problem
I don't know how they're going to
recharge all these cars in the next 12
years if they don't have the
infrastructure if they don't have I mean
the other problem too I've got a couple
friends with electric cars and one of
the complaints they're always making as
well I went to this place but the you
know the charger was down like I
couldn't use it like it wouldn't take my
card it wouldn't It wouldn't connect it
wouldn't charge like I've I've never
gone to the gas station to go put gas in
my car and it doesn't pump
um
ever ever
but people are having problems where
they go to recharge their cars and
they're like you know it's not working
or it's out of service or
um somebody's got a car plugged into it
now you got to sit around and pick your
nose and wait for the 45 minutes for
them to take their charge then you move
your car and then you wait another 45
minutes you've just wasted an hour and a
half two hours standing around doing
nothing right so they're not without
problems if you have a high capacity
charger in your garage and you don't
drive that far you don't need to use
like a charging Network outside of
something like the Tesla Supercharger
Network you're probably going to be fine
right you use it to run around get
groceries pick up the kids drop them off
they're boring cars nothing that
interested in them they look I don't
know what it is with electric cars like
why can't they make them look nice I
mean I think the
the Tesla Model S is probably a like a
handsome looking car like it's visually
appealing but I don't know what they've
done with the model 3 the model y they
just
they just don't look good they don't
they're not good looking cars you don't
visually look at them and go like that's
hot I like that I I go in the garage and
I look at my McLaren I'm like I'd I'd
hit that like you know it's different
with these electric cars and they're and
they're subdued they're more that's just
the way that they're building them right
anyway so our buddy Justin Trudeau is
saying you won't be able to buy gas cars
in about 12 years
he also happens to be one of the world
economics forums most favorite
brainchild of you know their group right
he's you know he's like the bastard to
uh step kid of Klaus Schwab you know his
best buddy sort of thing
um I don't think Trudeau went to Davos
this year from what I understand the
Deputy Prime Minister went Freeland uh
Christina Freeland I think is her name
anyway but that's where we're at I think
the amount of cars we currently have on
the road are something like three
percent in uh Canada so I'm really not
sure how we're gonna you know shift over
to this it's just it's just it doesn't
seem that practical I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out